fenera d the exomars mission the
international space station and the
erosita x-ray observatory these
planetary science missions have all been
affected by the russia-ukraine war i'll
explain how that conflict in europe is
rippling out into space and what the
long-term implications might be
to start we have to unpack the history
between the u.s and russia space
relationship many of those
collaborations date back to the early
1990s following the disillusion of the
soviet union it wasn't always a given
that the two countries would become
close partners and that the
international space station would be
their biggest joint venture in space in
the early 1990s an influential russian
physicist wrote that in the post-cold
war world space policy is foreign policy
human spaceflight became emblematic of
diplomacy and to some extent the
westernization of russia now let's fast
forward to today following russia's
invasion of ukraine on february 26th
just two days after the invasion those
long-standing relationships began to
fray dimitri rogazan who was the head of
ross cosmos the russian space agency
announced that it was giving nasa the
boot from venera d its planned mission
to venus the mission has been years in
the making with nasa playing an advisory
role to understand more about that
legacy and what the current tensions
might mean i called our space reporter
island woodward venera d is sort of
going to be was planned to be a
large-scale mission almost like sending
a rover to mars but since it's expected
to launch in 2029 and a lot can happen
between now and then the focus has been
on other aspects of space exploration
the near idea aside there is sort of a
more definitive impact that occurred to
a mission to mars just a few days after
for more than a decade scientists in
european countries and in russia had
been working on a new mars rover called
the rosalind franklin rover the exomars
mission which includes that new rover
had already been saddled with delays due
to funding and the pandemic exomars was
supposed to launch in september but the
european space agency has suspended
cooperation with russia and cancelled
the upcoming launch which was going to
use russian rockets the the delay is
significant because when you're trying
to send things to mars from earth the
way that the two planets orbits are
situated is that they're only close
enough to launch a spacecraft every two
years a delay means a two-year delay
after twitter threats from russia the
journal confirmed that roscosmos was
questioning russia's continued
involvement in operating the
international space station given that
the iss is like the crown jewel of u.s
russia space cooperation that seems like
a big deal because the iss orbit is low
it runs the risk of falling prey to
earth's gravitational pull so every so
often the iss needs a little upward
nudge to keep the lab orbiting safely
russian thrusters get that job done
ireland told me that commercial rockets
made by companies like spacex and
northrop grumman could step in and help
with tasks like delivering cargo
shuttling crew and those orbital
corrections in the meantime tensions
have fluctuated especially on twitter
thanks in large part to a video
depicting russian cosmonauts abandoning
an american astronaut at the iss a
russian state news agency shared the
video on social media with a caption
warning what russia withdrawing from the
iss would mean for the project the
russian state agency said roscosmos made
the spoof video but that claim couldn't
be confirmed
all that drama aside at least for now
operations on the iss seem to be going
as planned nothing has changed in the
last three weeks
the control centers operate successfully
flawlessly seamlessly while operations
on the iss continue largely unchanged
according to nasa another critical
instrument in space that's been turned
off at least for now it's known as the e
rosita x-ray telescope and it's part of
an orbiting observatory run jointly by
the russian and german space agencies
it's been mapping the the universe for
like the last two and a half years so
it's remarkable that they elected to
stop collecting data this conflict has
certainly prompted
several international scientific
collaborations to re-evaluate how
russia and russian scientists and
russian funding fit into their model
that's already rippling out to other big
scientific projects
but space is unique because it's a big
part of the country's identity
think back to the soviet space dogs
sputnik and uric argarin the first
person in space we sometimes forget that
the cold war between the us and the
soviet union played out largely in space
and the moon was a final battleground
now we could be seeing the beginnings of
a sequel to those times
if you like this video hit subscribe so
you don't miss any of our updates and if
you're interested in more ukraine
related news check out shelby holiday's
channel hasta luego and thanks for
watching